we're joined on the line by dr. Scott
Atlas he's a senior fellow at Stanford
University's Hoover Institution a member
of the institution's working group on
health care policy previous chief of
neuro radiology at Stanford Medical
Center dr. Atlas thanks so much for
joining the show again sure thanks for
having me so as we look at these
increased modeled numbers suggesting
anywhere from a hundred and thirty-four
thousand deaths to two hundred thousand
deaths by the end of August
yeah I'm frankly a little bit surprised
at the amount of press this is getting
given the fact that eventually these
lockdowns we're going to end everybody
understands that as the lockdowns and
more people will go out and then the
risks from covin 19 have not been
mitigated I'm wondering exactly which
factors do you think are lacking when it
comes to releasing people from lock down
and gradual fashion yeah if I can
clarify something about the models first
those figures that were just received
from the iame model have nothing to do
with locked on being released those
figures are just simply updates based
upon data coming in that we are already
seeing so the fact here is that these
hypothetical projections shouldn't be
obsessed over all they do when they
change every three to four days is point
out the inaccuracy of their own
projection this is not based on changing
policy that's point number one
now the core question was watch what
should be done on re-entry is that is
that what your question is yes sorry
about that so I mean the basic points
here are using what we know it which is
the the realistic approximation of
fatality rate and who's vulnerable we
need to focus point number one very
stringent access to the most vulnerable
people the tinderbox of people that are
living in nursing home and senior is
nursing homes and senior care centers
and what I mean by stringent
requirements in an already regulated
environment because you can't just walk
into a nursing home anyway should be
done things like actually requiring
testing okay you can't have somebody
who's coming in there and cleaning the
floors who might be infected or who's
touching these patients are working with
them this is sort of obvious point
number one targeted strict control point
number two is people who have mild
disease who are sick
have some kind of fluish symptoms
respiratory so they have to assume they
have the disease and self isolate you
don't need a test for them while you
urgently need is to protect the
vulnerable in the way you do that is to
let people know that if they're sick
they have to self isolate assume they
have the disease the other things to be
done really are to make sure that you
have not incited fear in the public and
instill rationale trust and in their
experience in self isolating and what I
mean by that is they know who's
vulnerable they know they're elderly
family members for instance people with
underlying conditions particularly
diabetes and obesity are vulnerable use
the standards of hygiene that we now
know no one knew about social isolation
before we know what social distancing is
but that doesn't mean confining people
into their homes
it makes no sense there's no real
evidence that it's better to be strictly
confined inside your home or that we
should keep K through 12 schools open
and I can talk about that in detail but
young children people in the K through
12 age group that we know overwhelming
amount of evidence that these people
have very little if any risk of serious
illness from this virus and essentially
zero risk of dying you don't have to
keep them confined in their homes or
even have six foot spacing between them
if you keep them confined in their homes
not only are you missing education but
you're locking up the ability of their
parents to go to work there's a massive
really harmful nature to some of these
restrictive policies similarly there's
no evidence to keep people inside and
lock down parks and beaches and outdoor
facilities that was done to prevent this
kind of very close proximity mingling
but even when we we know even if you
wanted to have that there's no reason to
close a park I mean that's just really
there's no evidence for that and what
these policies have done done is they
have done something very harmful not
just locking down medical care and
people are dying because of that and the
massive harm from the economic isolation
but they have instilled
fear in panic and people and you're
seeing probably where you live
certainly where I live in California I
see people who are driving or on inside
their own cars with no one else in them
wearing masks and believe me I'm not I'm
not implying something wrong with these
people or are under estimating their
fear I'm saying it is an indication of
the fear from very poor leadership and
very really lack of consideration of
science and using logic to use
appropriate policy so dr. Ellis it I've
been in the last couple of days
considering a question and it was
actually raised by a column that you
wrote for the hill in in sort of
contradiction to an article that was
written by a guy named Harris over at
the New York Times and this is with
regard to social distancing itself what
are the goals that we are attempting to
achieve here the reason that I'm asking
this question is because it seems like
basically we are now trying to figure
out what to do based on future
projections I'm in one hand you have
folks who say okay well vaccine will
come it will be imminent it will happen
quickly or there will be a therapeutic
that will happen quickly which would
suggest you lengthen lockdowns you
create lots of social distancing so as
to flatten the curve until we get to
some sort of deus ex machina that
radically changes the math on the other
hand there's the possibility that
nothing changes that we're two years out
we still don't have a vaccine there's
been no serious therapeutic that's been
developed that radically lowers the
death rate and then the question is why
wouldn't we have preserved herd immunity
among the nonviolent vulnerable
populations in other words you make sure
that the people who are most vulnerable
are protected you make sure that the
nursing homes are really well protected
you make sure that people who are obese
or who have pre-diabetes are staying
home as much as possible and are
isolated from other people and then you
actually encourage the 60 to 70 percent
of the population that does not have any
of these conditions to go out and you
actually want the Cova to move through
the population and create herd immunity
that's sort of the Swedish strategy it
seems like we've sort of split the baby
here where we are on the one hand
suggesting that we are not pursuing herd
immunity and on the other and and that
there will be some radical change that
will happen in the in the very near
future and at the same time we want
people to sort of go back to work and
sort of isolate and sort of not isolate
what is our goal here should our goal
here to be assuming that there's some
sort of radical change to the system in
the form of therapeutic or vaccine and
thus we should really mitigate
the amount of social contact we have
with one another or should we be
assuming that none of that may be
forthcoming and so we should actually
pursue her pursue her de mmunity because
every month we don't pursue herd
immunity is another month of lengthen
time where the economy is dead and where
huge percentages of the population have
to stay home okay so you're pointing out
really one of the major flaws of logic
and common sense honestly that's being
used by people including very smart
people the the point here is that there
is no reason to do some of these sort of
illogical isolation policies regardless
of if there is a vaccine or no I want to
come back to the vaccine point but the
goal of the of the policy this is your
first question
the goal of policy was stated and it has
been twofold stop the people from dying
who are the most vulnerable which that
goal honestly there's a problem with how
that was it sort of ignored in a sense
but to flatten the curve what does that
mean curve is nothing to do with number
of cases the curves to be flattened that
have been flattened are curves on
hospitalizations per day and deaths per
day to prevent overwhelming of the
hospitals and to understand that you
sort of have controlled the progress of
death there's a nuance to this that's
sort of gonna bore your audience but the
reality is flattening the curve has
nothing to do with changing the area
under the curve if you listen very early
on the point was to prolong and slow
down and somehow reduce the overwhelming
of the medical system and sort of in an
out-of-control way so that we could
administer care and control the kind of
you know out-of-control sort of
overwhelming issues but it was not
really honestly to reduce the deaths the
reduction of deaths should have it
should be this targeted policy of
protecting the vulnerable we know who
they are now the idea I want to mention
something about the idea of vaccines
there's this sort of naive
interpretation of what a vaccine
does and when it will come out okay and
this is not really I'm not trying to
criticize people but you get the general
public and even people in this debate
I've been very naive about this vaccines
are not magic wands typically speaking
you know it's very common that a vaccine
particularly for a respiratory virus
that has some evolution and changing
that occurs like let's talk about
influenza forty to sixty percent
effective and we've been working on
vaccines for influenza for many many
years and have a lot of experience
that's point number one there's a magic
wand here that all of a sudden it's a
hundred percent effective and we don't
know we have no idea about that but we
know from other infections that it may
not be the second point is that despite
the vaccines in influenza four hundred
thousand the six hundred and fifty
thousand people died in the world every
year from seasonal flu with the vaccine
okay so you know the vaccine is not a
magic wand point B about the vaccine is
that vaccines are not ready tomorrow
vaccines are not going to be ready in a
month the vaccine technology has
dramatically improved and things are
done with a massive amount of intention
and rapidity and an incredible effort by
the private sector and in the u.s. in
the academic sector as well as in the UK
and and elsewhere lots of vaccines are
being looked at probably a hundred
roughly and a couple of them have a
significant amount of promise when will
they be ready when will they be ready
for production when will they be ready
for implementation we're talking many
many months so we don't know exactly
when it's it's highly unlikely in my
view and it's impossible to predict
because I'll predict and I'll be I'll be
way off but not gonna be happening
before 2021 I mean almost certainly and
you know even with the best case
scenarios I mean we have to realize
vaccines are not magic wands meantime
there's a map we can't ignore this
massive harms from the current policy
extending total isolation is killing
people on the basis of the medical care
and a catastrophic
economic problem which converts into
health care and poverty and death all
over the world to the likes of which
really people have not really calculated
so final quick question for you doctor
atlas so there's been people who have
been pushing some Israeli science has
something called controlled Avalanche
which is basically make sure that
everybody who is vulnerable is protected
and then actually encourage people who
are younger to not social distance and
you sort of mentioned something like
this in your article for the hill so in
so is that something that we should be
seriously considering just saying if you
are under the age of 40 and you're
healthy you should go out you should go
to ballgames and if you get coronavirus
and then you get over it then you have
actually added to the health of the
country then this is really hitting the
nail on the head sort of with the basic
premise of immunology and decades of
knowledge about about viruses it's
actually a negative to interfere by
total isolation with herd immunity herd
immunity is necessary and it is the most
immediately available way to break the
connections toward the vulnerable in
this contagious sort of disease so it's
actually detrimental to lock everybody
up and it prevents the low-risk groups
like you're saying to get the disease
50% of people are zero symptoms over
ninety five percent of people probably
ninety nine percent of people have very
mild disease there's nothing wrong with
that in the lowest groups the focus
should be preventing the people who are
the vulnerable we know who they are it's
harmful to prevent mingling by other
people
well dr. Scott Atlas Hoover Institution
really appreciate your time sir and I
look forward to speaking with you again
soon okay thanks very much for having me
I hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit the subscribe button so you stay up
to date on all of our future content